Welcome...
Eggs Benedict.
Wha the-heh-heh-
I- (Wheeze)
I'm not-I'm not Benedict Cumberbatch.
I'm me. I'm Markiplier!
WHY DO I WANT DANCEY PANTS TO BE MAD AT ME?
Foxy is big ol' bag of dicks! (Ew!)
(Mark) THE--! [Hand Unit] For other options, press 4.
THERE'S NO NUMBERS!
I! CAN'T! PUT! ANY! NUMBERS! IN HERE!!!
BABY!!!
BABY!!!!!!
BABY, COME OUT!
BABY COME BACK!!
AHHHHHHHH!!!
Ohhhhhhhhhh god,  ohhhhhhhhhhh-hoe Gahad!
Aaaaaaaaaaa!
I'm tryin' guys! Im tryin'!
[Bidybab jumpscare]
AH! FUCKING FUCK!!
Shut the fuck up!
OOOOH!
NEIGH! (Horseplier)
DA DA DA DA DA DA DA!
DURDUR
Everything's okay!!!
[Mascot response audio] Everything is okay! Let's go back to sleep!
[Markiplier] WUDDOAYEDOOO?
*beeping*
FREDDY: BOO! MARK: AAHHHH!
*static*
DA-NA-NA-NA-NA-NA NUN!
Ballora!
DA-NA-NA-NA-NA-NA-NA NUN!
Don't kill me...!
BA-NA-NA-NA-NA-NUN!!
*Ballora's music box*
Sneaking!
You don't need to worry about me!
I just need to worry about me...
And don't mind the YELLING!
I YELL WHEN I'M
NERVOUS!!!!!!
We did it!  We're the best in the world!
And we are friends! For... Oh... Ever...
Ok. ._.
These casual bongos have turned sour!
[Hand Unit] There is no need to check on Baby tonight.
[Hand Unit] Please refrain from entering unauthorized areas.
Proceed directly to Funtime Auditorium.
[Hand Unit] You have been provided with a flash beacon.
*SURPRISE BITCH!*
OOOOO!!! K! WHAT THE FUCK!??
I, uhhhhhhhhhh...
Got "boned".
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
[Spongebob Theme] WHO LIVES IN A PINEAPPLE UNDER THE SEA?
What??
*singsong* Why is Ballora lookin' at me? Why is Ballora looking at me?
[Laughing] Why did I wiggle so darn much?
OH, HI!
WHO THE FUCK IS THAT?!?!?!?!
WHAT THE FUCK ARE YOU?!?!
*Turns to other side* I'll look at you in just a second, but HOLY SHIT!!
*HERES MINIREENA!*
AUUGGGHHHH! FUCK OFF!!!
WHAT THE FUCK!?
I'm- I'm fubber-nucked, I'm fubber-nucked, I'm fubber-knucked.
HEY! OH! WIGGLING! I'M WIGGLING!
*GOTCHA BITCH!*
I WAS WIGGLING!
I WAS WIG-WAGGLING!
I WAS WABBLE-JABBLING!!!!
Wowie zowie oopie powie.
HUAHHH.
Fucking...
Fucking...(2x)
Fucking...(3x)
FUCKING...(4x)
FUCKING...(5x)
FUCK!
OHHHHHHHHHH YES!
YES! YES!
It was 3 minutes! Fuck yeah!!
FUCK YEAH!!!
YES!
YESSSS!!
That was a good day at work,
OMNOMNOMNOMNOMNOM!
-- I get to keep my glorious crown and continue to call myself,
(smugly) The king...
of Five Night's at Freddy's.
Sorry, did I not say that right?
The....
K I N G!!!
Ow...
It's so wet!
*gross wet sounds*
Why is it wet??
Hi, Baby!
(Laughing) How you doing, you enjoying my body? (Baby shrugs)
You get outta here! (about the "Real" ending)
No way!
No, nuh-uh-uh, no, not happening. Nope.
Not- em- um- thats a no, That's a big NO.
[singing] ♪ Fudge, fudge, fa- fa- fa- fudge, fudge ♪
(10/10 XD)
♪ Fudge, fudge, fudge. ♪ (So wonderful..)
♪ There is no way that that is going to work. ♪
♪ It is a load of bullshit ♪
(Can I buy this song on iTunes?)
♪ And I hate it a lot. ♪
OOOHH NO! OH NO!!
OH NO! OH NO NO NO NO!
I WENT TOO QUICK!
NOOOOOO!!!
OH! WAS I SUPPOSED TO DO SOMETHING WITH THAT?
OH NOOOOOOOOO!
WAS I SUPPOSED TO GO BACK TO THE BEGINNING?
Alright, look, it's a two star!
It's a 2 star! (holds up 4 fingers) It's a two star!
No, that's a 4 star-- It's a two star!
2 for victory!
However the fuck that understands it...?
(What?!)
Oh god! Is baby on the way?
BABY's on the way!!!!
Oh sheet, this is Five Nights at Baby's!!!
I'M NOT GONNA MAKE IT!
*HI MARK! GIVE ME A KISS!* OH!!! HEY HEY HEY HEY!!!
I, uh, you get really skedaddle-y at 4 am? huh, don'cha?
I DID IT, YEAH!!!
I AM THE.... Ohhh my head...
Ohhh, I got light-headed.
OHHH! I got my Exotic Butters!
YES!!!!
And I buttered my popcorn from all around the world!
Well, I did it!
Place the crown upon my head!
Ow...
And then CALL ME...
THE
K I N G!!
OF FIVE NIGHTS AT FREDDY'S!!!!!
So, I don't think there's anything new.
[Hand Unit] Exotic butters.
Exotic butters. Hehehehe!
Exo- Exo- Exotic butters.
How long until someone makes a remix of...
[remix] Exotic butters
Welcome back! (Echoing)
Delightful Dip- Back- Back-
Exotic-
Your- Last- day on the job.
Delightful Dip- Back- Back-
Exotic-
[remix Fading) Butters butters butters butters butters butters butters butters......